[Aplausos]
colombia protesta contra la tercera
reforma tributaria del gobierno duque el
ejecutivo espera recaudar 23 billones de
pesos lo que equivale a 6 mil 800
millones de dólares a través de un
incremento de impuestos principalmente a
la clase media el punto más polémico de
la propuesta es que prevé que a partir
de 2023 los que ganen más de un millón
setecientos mil pesos unos cuatrocientos
setenta dólares declaren el impuesto de
renta una obligación que ahora solo
tienen los que ingresan más de tres
millones 900 mil pesos mensuales unos
mil 50 dólares en un país en el que el
salario mínimo es de 248 dólares además
aumentaría la tarifa de los servicios
públicos y agregaría un impuesto a
productos de la canasta básica el paro
nacional se celebra mientras que el país
vive sus peores días de la pandemia una
semana con récord de muertes y contagios
diarios con un lento proceso de
vacunación por lo que incluso algunos
detractores de la reforma piden que se
aplacen la jornada de movilizaciones
estoy segura que todos entendemos que
estamos pasando por un momento difícil y
que así como estaban haciendo un
sacrificio el sector productivo los
comerciantes los vendedores informales
los niños todos los deportistas también
desde el sector social y político puede
haber una adaptación para que su
legítima protesta se haga a través de
canales que nos generen menos riesgo la
legislación propuesta por duke que él
llama ley de seguridad sostenible tiene
un difícil camino en el congreso- la
rechaza el propio partido del presidente
el centro democrático por considerarla
impopular de cara a las elecciones de
2022 el rechazo en forma de paro
nacional tomará las calles de la capital
dentro del marco restrictivo con toques
de queda a las 8 de la noche